you talk about wanting to get full
transparency from a distributor but how
does someone do that
due diligence if a lot of people are
really good at you know hiding numbers
and and being evasive how do you have
you take ownership of that if if you're
getting someone that's giving you the
runaround cuz we've heard that from
other filmmakers where we've tried to
contact them and people can keep very
creative books they can so the way you
do that is you do before you sign the
paperwork so that's the key so it's not
after you sign the paperwork
once you sign the paperwork and you give
them the rights to your film or let me
put you let me touch it this way once
you give them a digi beta with a film on
it and you don't have anything in
writing that allows you to visit their
office look at their numbers do all
these things then it's it's out of your
hands basically so when you're dealing
with a distribution company it when I
mean fully transparent I I think they
should have a physical office that's
accessible to you not something you know
somebody based in Texas or Kentucky and
who has like a branch office in Los
Angeles that's only open during the AFM
that might be a warning to you so just
yeah just a for you know filmmakers to
know so you want to have a concrete
office that that has an open-door policy
that you can visit you want to know
where your film is going and one of the
ways to ensure that is don't give them
the film don't give them the film period
you hang on to it and and you say okay
you guys are going to get whatever 30
percent 40 percent or 60 percent of the
profit whatever but I Hannah I hang on
to the media so when you get a order you
tell me about the order and I'll supply
it and that suppose it like 99 cents per
CD charge that you want to charge me
I'll leave that I'll make the CD for you
I'll do the DVD for you no problems keep
your film with you and and I and I
stressed that too with like screeners a
lot of people are very flippant or
ambivalent about screeners yeah send me
a screen or send me a screen or don't
send people
unless it's you know you you feel their
legit and you feel that their there's
somebody that you're actually going to
work with be Zenith the AFM love people
like you didn't bring a screener it's
like no I didn't bring a screener are
you gonna buy the film no no I just want
to look at it well when you want to buy
it or if you really think about you know
if you really want to you know
distribute it because you already asking
me like what's who's a talent who shot
the film who's the director I don't know
this person I don't know XYZ so once
that film goes out of your hand
then you know it's pretty much over they
can do pretty much whatever they want
unless you are fortunate enough to have
Lionsgate buy your film which you know
it which is wonderful if that ever
happens but so keep the technology with
you keep your keep your media with you
that's key and if somebody wants to
distribute for you let them distribute
for you but you keep the goods and it
really shouldn't make a difference
because like if I'm a distribution
company and I say to red box that okay
red box I'm going to give you 1000 units
and you're going to give me $4,000 for
it and then you can tell your your film
guy like hey guys we're getting a four
thousand dollar check from red box
here's your two thousand here's our two
thousand can you get them four thousand
units of the film by the 31st of January
problems will send a red box right now
so I think that's a better way to work I
think the industry is is you have a lot
of people who and you know this is once
again this is a learning process but I
feel the the industry here and even even
more so abroad you have a lot of people
who are gainfully employed who are just
basically taking advantage of people and
and that's that's wrong and because
these people are artists and these
people are people that put their life
their hopes their dreams into making a
film and there they get taken advantage
of because to them you know you're
looking for that one person who believes
in your film and you and you might find
a smooth-talking disappear I love your
film I'm going to make it happen but you
know you know don't don't give up you
know keep you know protect your film and
protect your media
and dude in a smart way how do you feel
about online screeners someone gives you
a password-protected link to something
but they could still rip it yeah they
could so still it's soup do you have it
on a laptop you should ultima control of
it exactly show people exactly that's
what we did we took the laptop with us
to the afm and we could show them the
reels and everything right there
the trailer should be online you know
the trailer and a couple of reels so
people get the gist the film but but the
whole film you know you really should
keep that to yourself I feel and then
what about hiring an attorney to look
over the contract it seems like a lot of
people's oh I had my friend's dad look
at me that looked fine do you advise
someone spending whatever it is 400 $500
an hour to review someone's contract
because I think that's probably a good
idea I think if if you have one
distributor who's going to handle your
entire project for the next let's say
the contract is for two to three years
or if it's a five-year contract
that's renewing I mean spending like you
know four or five hundred bucks or even
like you know up to a thousand dollars
for that peace of mind for the next five
years is is well worth it
you know just skip your daily Starbucks
for a year you know you can do it I mean
it's important it's peace of mind and
then you can move on to your next
project without having to ever worry
about you know the last thing you want
to do is give your film to distributor
and then not be able to contact him okay
what's going on what's going on with my
film and so you just want to put
yourself in that situation so to sum it
up it sounds like all of the work that
you have to do to protect your media is
done beforehand and it's not done after
once it's done after it's it's out of
your hands it's out of your hands yeah I
mean you could get lucky and get a
legitimate distributor but my impression
is they're they're not very many them
around there they're just aren't you
know it's just a it's a shady market out
there
you